thank you alicia
members
could i
ask you all to stand
please
a minute silence
uh in respect of ukraine
we are all witnessing the war in ukraine
as it unfolds so before this meeting
commences i would like us all to hold a
minute silence to show support and pay
tribute
to all those who have lost their lives
and for those families facing
unspeakable challenges from the horrors
of war
just like to welcome you all to this
meeting of the council
i am councillor adrian osborne chairman
of baba district council
and i will be chairing this meeting
today
may i first of all remind you of some
domestic arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the stairs
cold water is also available in the
breakout area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room by the
following by following the fire exit
signs and meet on the ipswich town
football club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
could i also ask you to please switch
off all mobile phones or turn them to
silent
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and all training purposes
council
members
of the public met the council members of
the public and the press may record
film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public
and the press
are not lawfully excluded
can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence
thank you chair i have received
apologies for absence from councillor
grandin councillor mayberry councillor
gould councillor melvisi and councillor
busby thank you
thank you jan
declarations of interest by councillors
are there any declarations of interest
nope thank you move on to
item 3
bc 2134 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 21st of february
2022 for accuracy only
are there any issues with accuracy
could i have a proposal please
jan osborne
and the second to please
suez thank you
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the vote
thank you chair as this is a consensus
vote we will do it by show of hands all
those in favor please
thank you chair that is carried
thank you
item 4 bc 2135 announcements from the
chairman and leader
i refer you to paper bc 2135 for noting
thank you i would also like to take the
opportunity to remind you of the
chairman's fundraising dinner
on behalf of the chairman's charity on
the 13th of may
2022 at henderson hall
tickets can be purchased via the civic
secretary karen sayer
thank you
i would like to invite councilwood to
make his announcements
thank you chairman
firstly i'm pleased to say i don't have
much to report about covert this time
fingers crossed although infection rates
are very high it does seem to be much
less of a threat now that we have
effective vaccinations and other
therapies and we really can look forward
to a better year and of course see more
of us working back here in endeavour
house
i won't say too much about the terrible
events in ukraine at this moment as we
have a motion to debate later however
our councils will do everything we can
to support the homes for ukraine scheme
in line with the guidance provided by
the dluhc
it is essential that this scheme is a
success and that we can house as many
refugees as possible
we will support our residents and
communities so that they can offer those
spleen and russian atrocities the
warmest welcome to the uk
as you know the lga peer review team
visited us last week
and i'd like to thank those of you who
participated in the focus groups for
giving up your time and i hope you found
the sessions worthwhile
the reviewers spoke to over 200 people
members officers and external partners
which gave them plenty of material for
their task
they felt that everyone really engaged
with the process and they particularly
enjoyed their visits to sudbury and
stone market
the feedback we have got so far is
overall positive but as expected there
are things that we need to focus on that
need improving
you have been sent the presentation with
the initial findings and recommendations
and a full report will be published soon
i attended the spring dcn mini
conference in london yesterday it was
well supported by representatives from
around the country as well as senior
government and opposition mps
it was good catching up again with
colleagues on a lovely spring day stuart
andrew the new minister for housing gave
an update on what we can expect from
dluhc soon
he said that we could expect an
announcement about the local plan
process
another announcement about expanding the
availability of planning resources and
skills and also enhanced the compulsory
purchase order powers
he tackled some probing questions about
housing targets and local need committed
development rights empowering councils
to build particularly to deliver a
portal portable social housing
and financing to invest in
infrastructure ahead of sill receipts
also use of right to buy receipts and of
course problems with the planning
inspectorate
there was also an excellent panel
discussion about revitalizing high
streets this addressed a number of
themes including the lack of enough
public funding the need to include
private partners and therefore the need
for robust business cases and we also
heard that some councils have made good
use of section 215 notices to protect
assets at risk where the condition is
harmful to the area and to tidy up land
and buildings
and it was good to hear from others and
to know that we are all irrespective of
political control facing the same
challenges and looking for the same
solutions
thank you
item five to receive notification
petitions in accordance with council
procedural rules
non-received chair
thank you
item six
questions by the public in accordance
with council procedure rules
an unreceived chair thank you
and item seven questions by councillors
in accordance with council procedure
rules
non-received chair thank
you i'd like to go to item 8
bc 2136 overview and scrutiny committee
report
and i would like to invite council
mclaren to introduce bc 2136 which is
for noting
thank you chair uh due to the brevity of
the report because it was a calling
situation and the length of the
agenda
if you've got any queries i would
welcome them by email i will not be
discussing this paper thank you chair
thank you clarence
thank you
council mclaren
are there
has everybody all members uh happy with
the with putting their questions to
council mclarens in an email yep okay
thank you
item nine
i bc 2137
to review a review of the governance
model operated by baba district council
i would like to invite the monitoring
officer to introduce paper bc 2137 thank
you emily thank you chairman and good
evening councillors
uh this report is the culmination of the
work of the constitution working group
following the request by the council
to explore the pros and cons of the
committee system and the cabinet model
of governance
the members of the working group were
councillors plum busby jamison mclaren
and malvezi
some of the key issues that the working
group took into account when considering
the best model of governance for baber
were the role of all councillors in
decision-making and their ability to
represent their communities
ensuring that all decision-making is
transparent and accessible
engaging members of the public in
decision-making and ensuring that
decisions and the reasons behind them
are communicated
recognising that there are good points
about both the cabinet model and the
committee system and wanting to capture
the best bits of both
and making sure that the governance
model is efficient and workable
particularly in terms of the workload of
councillors and the number of members
actually available to occupy seats on
committees
during the all councillor briefing on
the governance model options
councillors asked me to prepare and cost
some options for different committee
systems
i have included some examples in
appendix a to the report
however it is quite challenging to
accurately cost these options as there
are so many variables in terms of the
number of committees their size and the
frequency of meetings
however what i have included are the
statutory requirements of a committee
system and some key assumptions in the
appendix
if the council does decide to implement
a committee system this evening
we will work with councillors between
now and the annual council meeting in
may this year
to determine the right structure for
baber
the full council then has the reserved
power to choose which committees it
wants to appoint
and to appoint members onto those
committees and elect the committee
chairs and vice chairs
finally chairman i would just like to
raise the issue of timing
which is something the working group
discussed at length
if the council decides to adopt a
committee system then the council is
locked into that model of governance for
a period of five years
this means that the next council to be
elected in may 2023 would be bound by
that decision
if the council decides to stay with the
cabinet model and implement some or all
of the proposed enhancements then the
council will retain complete flexibility
to revisit the committee model at a
later date
i'm very happy to answer any questions
on this report chairman and would ask
for a proposer and seconder for one of
the options contained in the
recommendations section
thank you
thank you chairman
i'm going to propose recommendation 3.1
a which is essentially leave things as
they are with no change at the moment it
will allow us to implement some uh some
of the recommended changes um and then
for the next council in 2023 to to make
a final decision based on how those
changes have worked in practice i
the um the report we've got in front of
us in section 4.7 does show some of the
clear advantages of the cabinet model
and i believe those advantages still
stand
um we've got also in in 4.15 of the
report
to interrupt the leader um can i ask
i i wanted to ask the question of the
monetary officer
because she's just outlined one or two
things can't we do that before we get
into debate i'm not in debate actually
i'm just making a well proposal then
you're making the proposal no i i want
to ask a couple of questions at the
moment and what she's just said
i think i'll finish
yeah i'm nearly done chairman nearly
done um
i am however um mindful and uh sensitive
to some of the
issues reported by the working group as
outlined particularly in paragraph 415
regarding uh engagement with
backbenchers and to that effect we've
already implemented some changes to to
how council operates but also you'll see
at 4.18 um paragraph 4.18 there's some
proposed changes to the to the cabinet
model and i firmly believe that they're
given the chance that uh they will prove
to be very effective and improve that
engagement significantly and therefore
that is why i wish to propose that
recommendation thank you chairman
before i um go to uh monitoring officer
can i have a second up please
cliver counselor arthy thank you
emily would you like to you're welcome
to take questions now chair all right
yeah
well we're into questions uh now
so
the questions will be uh three questions
per member
and it must be relevant to the subject
under discussion and must be a question
i didn't realize we were limited to
three questions but anyway
i couldn't hear actually who you said
was on the
working panel i did catch um mary
mccann's name
but i my question really was who were
they
how were they appointed
or selected
and was this open to everybody that was
my first question i have got others
thank you
okay i'm happy to answer that question
so the members of the working group were
councillors plum council councillor
busby councillor jameson councillor
mclaren and councillor malveezy
and the uh
constitution working group so i've got
community governance working group in my
mind as well the constitution working
group is appointed by full council at
the annual council meeting
and i'll keep the third one after i've
heard some of the other things um
if uh
at the end of this debate we wanted a um
recorded vote
will we be able to do that or are you
going to tell me that we've got to do it
via the electronic system because i
don't ever remember photon for that
i've under the impression that we can
have
our names called out and we can state
which way we wanted to vote but
i'm sure you're going to tell me that
this isn't allowed now and i don't know
when and how this was ever changed thank
you
so it's absolutely possible to request a
recorded vote which is five councillors
and need to make that request and then
it's at the chairman's discretion as to
how that recorded vote is conducted so
we can use the modern.gov system because
that obviously provides a form of
recorded vote in any case which is
published
alongside the minutes
but if the the chairman so um desired
and the the council wanted it you could
have a roll call style of uh recorded
vote
under the circumstances i feel that the
electronic vote will deal with the
problem of who voted for what so there
is a recorded vote there already
thank you
any other questions
counselor hinton
thank you mr chairman a question for the
first question for the monitoring
officer is we received an email from you
saying that if we had any questions on
this paper we should ask you first and
you would answer them before the council
meeting how many questions did you
receive and what were they because the
whole purpose of having a paper
presented to council is that questions
are asked and everybody on the council
hears the questions and knows whether
they're relevant to what they're
thinking or anything else
so that's the first question
thank you chair um
i think it's probably worth me actually
just saying the reason for asking you um
if you would like to pose any questions
was to give you an opportunity to ask
any more detailed or technical questions
that you might have ahead of the meeting
which of course could equally be
repeated in the public forum because of
course the process of asking questions
and having answers is really important
for the public's understanding of this
issue and this report
i don't know whether this is a positive
or negative but i received zero
questions
thank you mr chairman uh my next
question is
concerning the
the timetable
we were previously told that
if we voted for a change in system
today or originally was going to be
january
um
that it would come into effect at the
next annual council meeting which is in
may 2022
if
is that a statutory requirement that it
comes in at the annual council meeting
or can it come at any time
because if that is the case then of
course if we
postpone in inverted commas
the decision tonight and stay with the
status quo
then it'll be two years before anything
can happen not one year
thank you chair yes that that's correct
so it's a statutory requirement that any
change to the governance model can only
be made at the annual council meeting
um or come into effect at the annual
council meeting so if you made the
decision today it could be effective at
the earliest point from the annual
council meeting 2022 this year
you could of course choose to make a
deferred effective decision as well if
you don't make the decision the next
opportunity to alter the governance
model would be in may 2023
thank you
council hinton
and just to clarify that would mean
until may 2024
no it could come into effect in in may
2023 so you could revisit the committee
model decision after six months from
today effectively so that the six months
rule is passed you could then make a
further decision about reverting to a
committee system and that could be
effective from the annual meeting in may
2023
thank you emily
are there any other questions please
counsel a hard acre
which one do i press this one
um
i've got a tactical technical question
on this um
the members of cabinet my understanding
is would they receive an allowance on
top of their standard allowance for
participating cabinet
but it's not not a
financial benefit of being a cabinet and
therefore should they not
be declaring an interest in this vote
and not taking part
thank you
chair thank you for the question
all councillors have a dispensation to
participate in discussions about
governance models or about allowances
because of course it's not fixed who the
cabinet members might be so anybody in
this room could potentially be a cabinet
member and therefore you all have a
dispensation to allow you to participate
in this kind of debate
thank you emily
any other questions
sorry counselor hinton you've had your
three questions i thought i'd only had
two
i've counted three
am i allowed to make another question
chairman or are we
stifling debate
questions
based on that point monitoring officer
uh bearing in mind that the cabinet
system is
in the inverted commas gift of the
leader of the council does that not
rather sort of take the rest of the
council out of who gets the allowance
and who doesn't
thank you chair um the leader can choose
from any member of the council to form
their cabinet so
it doesn't exclude anybody
in that regard
are there any other questions for the
monitoring officer
councillor barrett
are there any other questions of the
monitoring officer
okay
thank you
thank you for that
i shall now um
proceed to the debate
and uh councillors will
be able to allow to speak for three
minutes and once only
who would like to start the debate
councillor
lindsay
two bigger pile i'll get you two nice
stuff
thank you chair uh
yeah i i um
i will vote against this because i'm in
favor of committee system
um
i feel we we haven't uh
you you just need to look at a list of
um procedural disasters that have
happened
uh with the cabinet system so far um
i mean from my point of view i'm sure it
wouldn't seem a disaster to
some members of other parties but it is
a disaster for democracy when
um
you have
the greens
being elected with the second largest
vote
after the conservatives
uh the third largest party after the
conservatives and the independence
and
them being excluded
from
john ward's cabinet
just to put it on record yes
jane was asked by
council award to be on the cabinet
she said give me a day to think about it
and when we the next day we're told no
that offer's been withdrawn
so we have never in the duration of this
council
been asked to join this lovely rainbow
cabinet the council award is proud of
calling it
so it doesn't work in that regard uh
we also
um
there's talking about things that went
wrong you just need to look at bellevue
first we had the premier inn disaster
all decided in cabinet then we have
uh this
the
kind of lack of debate really about the
choice of tender for who's going to
develop
uh
on on bellevue park
um
we've the there's we've had the um
people arguing in a pub
uh cabinet members arguing in a pub
about car parking u-turns over car
parking threatens to sue people
um talks of people being threatened in a
pub i don't know why you're looking
baffled this has been an email that's
been shared to all councillors
so it's actually bringing the the
council into disrepute
um
the the the answer that we're given the
fig leaf that we're we've thrown is
we'll make this we'll make it a more
uh you know kind of open cabinet by
having advisory panels well
you know
it doesn't work i can tell you this was
tried by the conservatives actually at
county council
um some time ago they tried to have
advisory panels
um
the problem with advisory panels it's
neither one thing nor the other and the
members of the cabinet will not want
them to be in public they will not want
um the minutes to be publicized and not
want the agendas to be publicised
so they aren't they're not proper
decision making bodies so everything
will be done in secret on advisory
panels so where what is the point
for someone like me
or a back venture in the conservative
group thank you very much to thank you
guys for watching
thank you
if it's in secret
who else would uh
counselor hinton
thank you mr chairman i'll just first of
all draw members attention to paragraph
4.15 of the report
uh and that where therein lies one of
the major problems with the existing
system of cabinet
in the
other ordinary members of the council
those who are not within the
gift of the of the leader uh feel left
out of things and i think that's why i
should be voting one of the reasons why
i should be voting against this proposal
i think that it's
spurious to say that if we make this
decision we're locking the next council
in to to that decision
because there is uh
no reason at all why
we couldn't uh
have
changed things
not quite before the five years because
we've got that five-year lock-in which
is a wonderful part of local government
which stops us from doing what we want
to do
but um
there's no reason at all why the the
next council shouldn't have to wait the
same as this council has had to wait to
get rid of the cabinet system
thank you councillor
melanie barrett
thank you chair um i'm going to support
um
option a um the leader and cabinet model
um
because one of the
one of my reasons is because of the
number of councillors that we now have
in this council
it's lower than it was when we had this
model previously and i don't think that
we can really successfully fill all the
committee places but also
one of the reasons that has been cited
as
the problem that this is supposed to
address is the lack of engagement from
the back benches
but at recent uh cabinet meetings that
i've been to there's been very few
councillors there so if that is the
the problem then there is an alternative
way to address that and i and that's the
the um the model i am going to be
supporting
thank you
anybody else wishing to speak councillor
davis
yeah thank you chair um i thought i'd
give members the benefit of my
experience having been on
two cabinets but also knowing the
committee system as well
um in 2017 when the
cabinet system was brought in
it was a
not not great for the first year um
then council john ward took over as
leader
and uh he
made during that time the pledge that he
would try to make it more inclusive
and he invited an independent to come on
i was asked if i would join
there was a big debate among our group
and i know others whether i should or
not you know join the enemy as it were
but my my thought was
being among it try and make a difference
and say my peace
which i i did
had a good portfolio
basically customer services fantastic
team fantastic people and i was really
pleased with the things we were able to
get done in that time
at the same time it was a year of
squabbling all among the conservative
members themselves
john showed his leadership
so the following year when he asked me
again if i would join following the
election when i was re-elected asked me
again
and and but obviously it was more
inclusive this time because the numbers
had changed um clive and john got
together to put together the cabinet but
i was more than happy to see john as a
leader because i think he's a good
leader
i think he's hamstrung at times
by his own members but you know that's
the job he has i totally agree with
councillor lindsay
you know um especially after first year
we should have had we should have had a
green on board um
the mechanics of that
i think he um he has a slightly
different version of how we all saw it
but either way yeah a green should have
been appointed at some point
and then the cabinet itself i thought
was absolutely superb
um some great cabinet members on there
when there were eight of us
and then there was a
another squabble among the conservative
group
which led to john and i'm well aware
this is true
um be enforced if you like or certainly
manipulated
threatened whatever you want to call it
into bringing two more
conservatives onto the cabinet
that meant a very good conservative
colleague lost her job as on the cabinet
she wasn't happy with the way she was
treated by the conservatives so resigned
and then came to the independence and we
were more than happy to nominate her to
ask john to put her on the cabinet as an
independent and so liz malvesi carried
on with half the portfolio from before
part of the dispute was liz
along with john had introduced a
reduction in the free parking from three
hours to one hour
um
and they had introduced that
the independence along with um dave
busby from the uh davis
the time is up thank you thank you
councillor dog dawson
council dawson
if if i may just correct that i would
just like to say um that
the microphone is on
i'd just like to say council awards
certainly wasn't forced into making any
decisions with regarding bringing new
members on
both simon and i have our own businesses
and it's not something we would
particularly really relish it's a lot of
work and so i'd like that to be
corrected
thank you thank you it's enough
councilman
point of order chair is the a member not
allowed to make his assertions uh
without them being contradicted by
another member simply that otherwise we
go to indeed yahboo sucks
which i think frankly is a little bit
beneath us
i think uh
members i think we're here to debate the
possibility of a change of the
two committee or the cabinet role so i
don't want to get into personal details
and
working on on the assumption that
somebody is wrong or somebody is right
so can we just stick to that please
thank you is there anybody who wishes to
take part counselor beer
thank you mr chairman
um
well
i think the cabinet's remote
from us and from the general public
and that goes on both sides of this
chamber
disappointed mr chairman that you can
veto and not allow us to have this vote
i don't ever remember voting to give you
those powers but apparently we must have
done somewhere along the line so i have
to accept what you've said
but this just goes to show how
how we ignored the the the backbenchers
and i'll pick up some of the points that
different members had commented on um
you know
i had a motion for car parking
uh which got through this council
and um i'm still waiting to be involved
in it
uh
i was told there was some chat called
bruce who
we had the phone number i contacted him
still waiting to hear from him i've
never heard or seen of any of these
officers come to great corner
where i could have shown them around the
district around the area of my area
where we got these problems where some
of the solutions that we could put into
place that's never happened so there's
been no involvement
i think
a member opposite uh tried to take
comment or credit on the car parking
charges look at that fiasco had that
came to a committee
most likely it would have been thrown
out there and then it certainly wouldn't
have ended up like it did where it went
backwards and forwards and one member
had the right in the end to decide to do
it or not
didn't listen to the voices in this
chamber because it was quite clear
unless you'd got uh blocked ears or
something it's quite clear that the
members present
lots of them were against this charging
and yet it's still funded on as though
it was the right thing to do
that was a fiasco mr chairman nothing
else
so it says yes that
you know that this cabinet system is
better is wrong it works
when there's a complete majority of one
party whether it's this side or that
side it works then it doesn't work like
it does at the moment
anti-social behavior that was another
thing that i've constantly argued for
and we're still doing nothing about it
there is still no great movement on that
and no involvement of us members
who've got these problems in our areas
and it's not just
um
confined to my area it's throughout the
district but we should have been
involved and we're not and to suggest
that we keep your elite cabinet in in um
opposition is wrong i know my time is up
thank you very much
i'm well aware of that
thank you cancer beer
uh councilman crawl
thank you chair i'm not sure about
elites i've never felt particularly
elite
however
like councillor davis i've been on both
sides of this equation um both in
committee system and cabinet system and
i've had the unique opportunity of
having chaired scrutiny
uh during a cabinet system
and having seen how pathetic scrutiny
was in the under a committee system
there's no fact there's no doubt about
this by the way you just look at the
constitution the powers of scrutiny and
the importance it holds
since then i've gone on to become a
member of that cabinet so i've seen
cabinet from both sides scrutinizing
cabinet and being on that cabinet and
being prepared to be scrutinized
i wasn't originally in favor of cabinet
i've stated this on many occasions
but having seen it in operation and i
would have said under john ward as
leader i think it was effectively
being run very well the introduction of
independent in the first case and
possibility of other members being
involved
what we perhaps call the rainbow
coalition i have to say i've never
regarded this as a coalition it's a
supply and confidence arrangement we
will supply as long as we have
confidence and that's my personal view i
stated that before
i think we are not in a position to make
changes that will affect the next
council in 2023
we need to see what that election result
produces making a decision now will
commit that council and all council for
five years i don't believe that's
appropriate for us to do that today
we should defer it as long as we can
which i would suggest is probably in
about a year's time ready for the next
election it may be that it's a decision
the next council wishes to make and
let's be frank about it none of us know
what the make up that council might be
politically so we'd be
basically
second guessing and committing people
that really
won't have had a say in it i don't think
that's appropriate i will voting for
option a
thank you council macro councillor
parker
thank you very much um chair so i i find
myself in a curious position where i'm
uh agreeing wholeheartedly uh with uh
with what councilor lindsay has said but
also picking up some points that the
council of beer has raised as well chair
and and coming to a point specifically
that councillor beer
stated
was that cabinet works especially well
in my opinion where you have a thumping
majority
and if i'm not mistaken
weber district council has only enjoyed
that situation once since it's in
inception in whenever that was 1973. so
i agree wholeheartedly with councillor
lindsay actually that
whilst no model of
of of governance is perfect
actually the committee system is is the
better system uh for for baby district
council
however that said i also agree uh with
councillor mccraw down here that it is
not for this council to determine
how the next council's
governance should should feature that is
for the next council
there's many in here that may not be
returned at that council it is not for
us to determine uh
next council's uh governance model it is
for them uh when when they're returned
so
i will be voting for for option a
thank you
counselor
counselor arthi do you wish to speak
you've already spoken i'm afraid
councillor hinton
point of information mr chairman for
councillor beer if he'd been at the ons
yesterday he would have seen that there
were
36
cctv cameras between hadley and sudbury
to control anti-social behavior amongst
other things
but there was no consultations to where
they went
thank you
thank you
is there any wish anybody that hasn't
spoken wish to speak in debate
councillors
thank you chair
um just a couple of things we are all
made aware of any cabinet decisions
because we do get an email telling us so
we have the option to look at those
and the other thing is
we are all elected to represent the
people that voted for us
taking party political
things out of it
and i agree with the part that you said
about you know we cannot change this
because we don't know if we'll be here
in another 14 months
so i will go with the option that john
suggested thank you
thank you councillors
that's the debate i would now um
thank you i'll now ask the corporate
managed governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
oh sorry
sorry sorry council ward do you wish to
add anything
uh yes thank you uh chairman i do
actually um uh just just a few points
i'm very happy with the uh
membership of the present cabinet i have
brought in some extra members um for
very specific reasons uh i did separate
the environment portfolio because it was
huge and i felt that climate change
biodiversity sustainable transport
needed a portfolio in its own right
so
i'm happy with it and stand by those
decisions
the points that council bears made about
parking and antisocial behavior sorry
but um
a lot of progress has been made on both
of those things speak to councillor
dawson on parking she will give you that
update there's been plenty of
opportunity for members to engage on
both of those subjects
and finally i just wanted to pick up on
a couple of things that uh council
lindsay has said um
i'm not going to comment on what goes on
behind closed doors uh in in a pub when
people have a drink and get together and
have a chat
but i will say that um
i dispute his assertions about how those
advisory panels that we're proposing are
going to work
um we can quite easily make sure that
the proceedings of those are are made
available in terms of formal minutes but
also
his allegation of the use of the word
secret we do not and never have had
secret meetings at this council they are
not allowed we have confidential
meetings but we never have secret
meetings nothing is ever done in secret
so please do not make that uh assertion
because it is not correct
um i won't add anything else everyone
said uh what everything i would uh want
to say and agree with concerning the
proposed recommendation so thank you
chairman council wars and apologies for
not allowing you to come back straight
away so i've now asked the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for option a for for you to cast
your vote thank you
has cancer beer left the meeting right
okay thank you
okay thank you
so the vote is 18 4 and 8 against and
that vote just for clarification will be
shown on the website tomorrow morning
so
that is carrie
that vote is carried
i now like to go to uh
10 on the agenda
[Applause]
item 10
bc 2138
okay members please
code of conduct for councillors
i would like to invite the monitoring
officer to introduce a paper bc2138
thank you
thank you chairman i'm pleased to
introduce this report which asks the
council to adopt the new model code of
conduct as its own local code of conduct
the model code was developed by the
local government association following
the recommendations made by the
committee on standards in public life
the new code of conduct is accompanied
by a set of guidance which gives greater
clarity to councillors and complainants
about the scope of the code and the
definition of behaviours which would be
in breach of the code
if the council agrees to adopt the new
code it will come into effect from the
annual council meeting in may 2022
there will be training for councillors
on the new code the format of which is
currently being considered by the
suffolk monitoring officers group
currently the same suffolk local code of
conduct has been adopted by all tiers of
local authorities across suffolk which
has significant benefits for councillors
who are members of more than one council
we intend to maintain this approach and
will be recommending the adoption of
this new code to town and parishes in
our area
i'm happy to answer any questions
chairman and would ask for a proposal
and secondary for the recommendation
councillor haran
a secondary police
council mccrory thank you
all right we're going to questions and a
reminder that uh i will only
have three questions
by each member
council parker
yeah thank you chad um question uh for
the monitoring officer if i can to what
extent please um
with regards to the declaration of local
non-pecuniary interests it's um uh it's
shown on page 59 for members it's item
seven eight and nine to what extent
do the disclosure rules for
non-pecuniary interests
differ
from how they are now because i'm i'm
conscious that you mentioned the word
clarity having having read it i would
suggest that it offers
anything but actually um so could you
could you explain how those rules differ
uh or how they're proposed to differ as
to how they are now please
thank you chair so um the current system
of pecuniary and local non-pecuniary
interests is based on the
wording that's contained in the localism
act uh 2011.
um the recommendations of
the um
committee for standards on in public
life were that there should be an
additional category of interests which
were other disclosable interests and
that captures things like
positions of
trust so trustees directorships
management positions on outside bodies
charitable charitable groups and things
like that so there is a section in the
guidance document that accompanies this
report that talks a bit more about that
but i think it's one of the very
specific things that we will need to
provide some training on for for all of
us to to really have that thorough
understanding of these are the
categories of things that you need to
declare and these are the
under the legal system and these are the
additional things that you will need to
declare under our own local arrangements
now the questions
okay council dawson
um yes to the monitoring office
um i just wonder whether
can you provide clarity
regarding the code of congregate and
members external roles for us
i know they're doing that in parliament
as well at the same time with the lga
and i should just like confirmation that
treating fellow councillors with respect
includes members roles or subsequent
employment outside the immediate council
business but potentially influencing it
thank you for the question um anytime i
answer that chairman
the um current code that we operate and
indeed the new revised code
are both very clear about the capacity
test
so a counselor has to be acting in an
official capacity to be captured by the
code of conduct that doesn't mean they
they're not regulated perhaps in a
professional capacity by some other
regulatory body
now the new code differs slightly
because it changes the um sort of
presumption around whether you're
acting in a personal capacity from you
have to prove that you're not acting as
a counselor too you're likely to be
presumed to be acting as a counselor
unless you can prove otherwise so it it
kind of changes the emphasis
in terms of if it's very clear to an
ordinary person that you are only making
that comment or acting in that way in an
official capacity or because of
knowledge that you have as your role of
counsellor it will be captured by the
code of conduct
interestingly the government have just
published their response to the
recommendations made by the committee on
standards in public life and one of the
things that the committee recommended
was that when um operating on social
media counsellors should always be
presumed to be acting in an official
capacity and the government's response
says actually no we're not going to
accept that recommendation because we
need
members who are in elected office to be
able to
differentiate between their personal
views and the views that they hold as a
councillor so the government has
actually said that they're not willing
to go as far as saying that all social
media activity would be presumed to be
in an official capacity so that's to
give you a flavor of how that works
council mclaren
thank you chair
to the monitoring officer
my concern is around parish councils
having discussed this with them i was
aware there was a dearth of knowledge
about this the existing code of conduct
recognizing there is a system for the
support of parish councils
um i am concerned that it's not
sufficient is there anything that we as
a council or as as members
can uh
enable and empower this new code of
practice amongst parish councils thank
you
thank you
and that's a really good question and we
are currently working very closely so so
the suffolk monitoring officers group so
um all the monitoring officers across
suffolk get together and and discuss
matters of interest and particularly
those of us with town and parish
councils have been talking in depth
about the training that we'll provide
for town and parish councils that choose
to adopt this new model code and we're
working very closely with the suffolk
association of local councils on that so
there will be training in a variety of
formats some of that will be
face-to-face some of that will be
e-learning some of that will be virtual
training sessions
and we're also looking at how we can uh
use the the fantastic resource we have
in all of you as spokespeople for the
district council and taking that message
out to your town and parish councils as
well so we will be furnishing you with
information so that you can talk to
towner parish councils about that as
well as the support that comes centrally
from selk and from each of us
individually as monitoring officers
thank you chair thank you emily
council macro
i just wanted to make an observation um
in case members were unaware of this
that this was subject to a consultation
i think a couple of years ago
and many members were involved in fact
in making uh their responses as to what
they thought
a revised code of conduct should include
and all i can say is that i mean codes
of conduct um if you just look at the
nolan principles everything else falls
from that and follows from that
basically a code of conduct is just
reminding you to do what you should be
doing anyway
and if you follow those basic rules i
don't see an issue
the detail
we have a monitoring officer who can
advise on those things and i think there
will need to be training there's no
question this is this is a little more
complicated than the previous stafford
code which i've been
spending a lot of time looking at
recently
thank you uh council macro
any other questions oh councillor arthur
yeah just a quick one
follows on from what councilor parker
said about how this is supposed to
clarify issues around um
interests and behaviour um i just
wondered has it clarified anything with
regard to freemasonry and
um disclosing interests
there is uh still no requirement for
elected members to declare membership of
freemasonry or any other friendly
societies it is a requirement for
officers interestingly but not for
elected members
any other questions
is the case i
would like to now move into debate
council will only be allowed to speak uh
once for three minutes and this will be
timed
who would like to start the debate
emily have do you wish to add anything
no thank you chad
thank you
and uh
it was the second one
are you do you wish to say anything
my apologies that's okay
uh just to say chairman this paper came
before audit and standards at the last
meeting that i chaired in um
january we asked many questions that
have been asked tonight but at the end
we gave it a good um thorough
examination and um
were happy with it we were a bit
concerned about um
capturing covering some of the things
that go on at paris council level
because we are aware that i want to do
hot spots around on that but then we
don't um
judge them anyway but we thoroughly
backed it there's lots in here that we
thought were better capture more things
so we um
we backed it to the hilt and
uh would advise everyone to do so
tonight we obviously don't judge our own
that goes to other people
but it's what everyone in suffolk is um
signing up to so
we will judge other people um on this
model
so thoroughly recommend it's a good
piece of work chairman thank you
apologies for the sure i need to speak
as a sector
um i'll now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for councillors to cast their
vote
problems as well
it's not it's not coming up so could you
try again thank you
chair that is 24
4 and one abstention so that is carried
out those carried members thank you
i'd like to move to uh item 11
bc 2139
community governance review and i refer
to the updated appendix a in the table
papers
and i would like to welcome edward
mccready corporate manager for
electrical services
to the meeting to answer any technical
questions that may arise
i'd
like to invite councilwood to introduce
paper bc 2139 and to move the
recommendation in the report thank you
council ward
thank you chairman i'd like to introduce
paper bc 2139 the proposal for a
community governance review this year
the council is required under the local
government and public involvement in
health act 2007 to periodically carry
out a review of the boundaries and
governance arrangements for the paris
and town councils and unparis
communities within the district
it's been some time since this was last
done about 20 years ago and we are
required to keep our area under review
every 10 to 15 years
there have been a number of requests
from parishes
for a review and so we have deemed it
appropriate to conduct a district-wide
review now
the terms of reference are provided in
appendix a and together with the report
explain the rationale purpose and
timetable for the review
the review will start on the first of
april and will be completed by december
with any new arrangements coming into
force before the elections in may next
year
the report
proposes that the review will be
conducted by the community governance
working group
and which comprises councillors norman
and parker
supported by the electoral services team
and the group will report its
recommendations to council
so i propose a recommendation in this
report
thank you chairman
thank you jen
councillor osborne thank
you right
questions and debate
i will now move to questions
um and once again
councils may ask up to three questions
however they must be relevant to the
subjects under discussion and must be a
question
thank you and you would like to start
councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman
um just a quick one really concerning
this report is it possible to have a
copy of the report where it makes it
clear that this is about electoral
boundaries and not parish boundaries
because i believe the parish boundaries
were instituted uh many many years ago
whereas with this is to do with
electoral boundaries and the size of
parishes concerning electoral boundaries
and not
effectively changing or renaming
parishes as per the ancient books of
law in the country
did i ask
councillor mccready to
answer that technical question
thank you chair this is about all local
government
parish structure and town council and
power structure so technically the
boundaries can be changed or merged
uh some councils in circumstances where
somebody wants to take into a housing
estate or remove an area
as opposed to an ecclesiastical parish
any other questions
counselor arthi
yeah i'm really pleased with with um
councillor parker being on the group but
i don't actually remember nominating him
um so i'm not quite sure how the group
was i've just tried to find out when
when we actually put this group together
all i could find was reference to mid
suffolk needing one and we didn't at the
time which was um two or three years ago
any other questions oh did you want me
to answer
thank you that's also a working group
that's appointed at annual council
anybody else
question
council lindsay
thanks you just
just um
can clarify why we're having one now
thanks
you chair i i
i inherited this when i joined the
council in october it's something that's
been outstanding
and it's a matter i took up with the
monitoring officer and chief executive
when i arrived
it's something that it takes time to do
and that means we would have new
structures in place ready for the
elections in 2023
so it hopefully refreshes and takes us
forward for the next 15 20 years
thank you mr
councillor holt
thank you chair
would this review actually cross
boundaries from district to district so
could we actually lose a parish or gain
a parish or a town
we are we cannot go or change district
boundaries or electoral arrangements it
is purely the parishes and the elect the
local community government arrangements
inside the district boundaries
councilman crawl
i just wanted to um confirm my
understanding this concerns civil
parishes and i think the word parish
often confuses people words parish
councils
parish churches parish boundaries they
often coincide i just want to correct
that absolutely
right here so the civil parish and the
ecclesiastical parish might have exactly
the same boundary that in this instance
my understanding is that that's not
necessarily the case
is that correct
that is correct uh i'm not an expert on
ecclesiastical parishes and some of them
as we you know date back to
times well before ourselves but in terms
of civil parishes this is the boundaries
we're looking at
thank you
councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman that clears up the
question that i put earlier on but
another question that i've got it says
following a number of requests from
parachutes for a review who's actually
asked for the review we've got 80 some
odd parishes across the district uh and
yet we're doing a review of the whole
district how many parishes have actually
asked for a review
thank you chair apologies i don't
actually have that information to hand
i've had contact with one
parish meeting that's requested a review
a number of times and a couple of
parishes have informally contacted us
about about electoral arrangements
thank you
oh
our chief executive
thank you i just wanted to emphasize the
point that i think council awards said
at the start that we are obliged to
carry out a review on a regular basis
and we are overdue that review so even
if no parish council had requested it
we'd still have to be doing it but as mr
mccready has already said that isn't the
case we have got requests as well that
we need to be picked up of course as you
find with any changes and counsellors
may recall when we made the changes at
the district council level towards if
you make change in one place it has a
knock-on effect on other places so it's
easier in many regards will be it's a
bigger piece of work to look at the
whole rather than only looking at
subsets of any part of the district
uh thank you chair um i understand this
is to go to all of our i think it's 78
parishes is that correct
i have to say um
i find this difficult to understand
what's actually being asked
um is it the physical boundaries
you know could boxford say look we'll
have half upholstered or is it that sort
of um is it that sort of request is that
what we're actually asking this thing is
about name changes maybe mr mccready can
help me because to be honest if this
lands in 78 parishes
i think all the district councillors
will want to know more because we're
going to get a lot of questions
and i for one i'm not sure what the
answers will be so i think we need a bit
more clarity of what
this is offering
um is it just boundary changes name
changes we need a lot more
clarity here chairman we really do
thank you chair
the review allows the council to make
decisions on all aspects of community
governance the boundaries the electoral
arrangements whether a parish or town
council is warded
whether a parish meeting is allowed to
form a parish council where the parish
councils wish to
to merge
there's a lot of flexibility at the
moment it's a blank canvas to us we're
not pre-empting any ideas but we will be
writing to the parishes to invite them
to come up with suggestions or
recommendations which they feel would
represent
efficient government or local government
or community governments in their area
or their parish
any other questions
okay so
i'd now like to
go into debate
and once again
councillors will be allowed
three minutes
and
to speak and
once only
thank you
who would like to start debate
fair enough
to come back yeah
councilwood do you wish to add anything
no thank you chairman thank you i shall
now
go to the vote
and i'll ask our governance officer
civic
uh to actually conduct the vote
thank you chair that is now showing in
blue for councillors to cast their vote
are you able to vote
okay can i take your vote manually
please
thank you
chair that is 21 votes four one against
and three abstentions
thank you very much that uh is carried
right now to move to um
item 12 bc 2140 designation of the
section 151 officer role
and i would like to invite the chief
executive to introduce paper 2140 thank
you
thank you chairman and good evening
again councillors um as i'm sure all
councillors are aware the statutory
positions in the council of section 151
officer monitoring officer and head of
paid service have to be appointed at
full council that they are within your
gift
and as i know you definitely are aware
our current section 151 officer
catherine steele
is due to retire at the end of april and
i'm sure you won't miss opportunity to
to thank her again as you have in the
past uh in terms of the work that she's
done for the council but what that does
mean as you would expect is that we've
been out to recruit uh to replace
catherine so to appoint to the assistant
director for corporate resources
that was an exercise carried out by
penner executive recruitment on our
behalf it was a comprehensive process
that involved candidates
not only applying but producing their
own video and then going through a
series of technical interviews
stakeholder panels with other finance
officers from other partner
organizations
a panel meeting of councillors a panel
of the senior leadership team and then
ultimately an interview panel as well
and as a result of that as you no doubt
will have seen within working together
melissa evans was successfully appointed
as the assistant director for corporate
resources but tonight you are therefore
asked to not only accept her as that
appointment but add to that in terms of
formally appointing her as your section
151 officer as well and so i'd ask for a
counsellor to propose and second if i
may
oh i'm here
i don't know what happened there i've
moved to the right
some would say impossible
um it gives me great pleasure to propose
uh melissa to this post um having worked
with this over the number of years it's
been great to be able to
see her career development um and also
to ultimately end up as our 151 officer
so
and i'm looking forward to
sorting out next year's finances with
melissa we've already started that task
ahead of us to make sure that babe is
not the pauper anymore compared with
mid-suffoc
that's a task for you
anyway so that's my proposal so vote for
her please thank you
thank you council barrett can i have a
second to please council ward
i would be delighted to second this um
i was on one of the interview panels and
melissa put in a very strong performance
she was an excellent candidate
and i'm sure she'll make a brilliant 151
officer she's got a hard act to follow
catherine has been a wonderful 151
officer and i've enjoyed working with
her in my position as leader but also as
a previous finance portfolio holder and
i'm sure melissa will step up and and
will fill those very big shoes um and i
support everything councillor barrett
has said as well
so
welcome melissa thank you award
does anyone have any questions or
anything to say on this appointment if
not i intend to move straight to the
vote
okay i should now um
ask the corporate manager governor and
civic office to conduct the electronic
vote thank you thank you chair that is
now showing in blue for councillors to
cast their vote
chair that is 25 votes for that is
unanimous
[Applause]
uh melissa i'm glad to inform you that
that is carried
and uh
welcome welcome to the
job of section 151 it's nice to have you
there and obviously i'd like to
give my
wholehearted uh
thing with with catherine on the years
that i've known her and what she's done
it's been you've been magnificent thank
you
uh bc
uh
2141 pay policy report
before this item commences i will ask
members of the senior leadership per
team apart from the chief executive and
catherine steele
to leave the meeting while the item is
discussed
this evening i would also
like to welcome
steve davis employer services specialist
from london councils to answer any
technical questions and i would like to
welcome him to the meeting
i'd now like to invite the chief
executive to introduce paper bc 2141
thank you chairman and good evening
again councillors and so councils you
will recall that you considered a report
very similar to this not the same at all
but very similar to this back last
september and there was a lengthy debate
in this council chamber and ultimately
that vote was lost so the proposals were
rejected
at that time i alongside the other
senior leaders leadership team couldn't
be in the room so just by way of
explanation as to why myself and
catherine are able to stay tonight
that's because i've specifically asked
the leader and he's agreed to remove any
reference to myself from the report so
there are no recommendations in relation
to me as chief executive and as i've
already explained earlier in the evening
um
catherine steele is leaving us at the
end of april so she's no longer
conflicted in terms of being able to
hear to support although i noticed she
has disappeared from the room so
hopefully she will come back shortly
in terms of the report itself as i say
you had a lengthy debate at the time in
particular arising from that debate and
also through further conversation with
mid-suffolk councillors at the report at
mid-suffolk just for reference if you
weren't aware was withdrawn following
baber's rejection of the proposals but
outside of the meeting as you know
there's been lots of conversation in
each of your group meetings and via
email in order to try and tackle some of
the concerns that were raised both in
this council chamber and beyond as a
result of that report
you'll recall that as a result there
were approximately 23 different issues i
think it was that were raised by a
combination of councillors and actually
following the various discussions i
think that rose to more like 27
different issues that were raised by
councillors each of those we have sought
to address within both the covering
report that you have tonight and in
addition to that within the ilga east of
england lga appendices that you have
with you and just by way of explanation
as to why steve uh davis is with us this
evening unfortunately michelle kirk who
wrote the original report and suffered a
bereavement so she's not able to join us
and so steve has very kindly stepped in
to be here this evening if there are any
technical questions and we also have
suzanne hughes who's our head of hr and
od if there are any specific hr
questions that you may have
that was all i was going to say but i
think it might be useful if i just take
you briefly through the recommendations
themselves and then if there are any
questions more than happy to try and
support you you will i know be familiar
with the recommendations because they
have been discussed outside of the
meeting in advance
so the first two recommendations and i
will be brief i promise the first two
recommendations are in relation to
salaries themselves that's the salaries
of our directors within the cd
leadership team that's recommendation
3.1 and 3.2
the recommendation in terms of salary
scales follows what was proposed
back in last september by the east of
england lga but what has changed as a
result of several comments by lots of
councillors on both sides of the chamber
is in relation to the number of spinal
points that form that grade as you may
recall east of england lga recommended
at three spinal points you were much
more comfortable with five spinal points
which is what the current arrangements
are and i should say in relation to pay
one of the reasons why
this needs to be looked at at this stage
not least in terms of the current market
position but we've found ourselves in in
this situation because those pay scales
haven't been reviewed for upwards of 10
years nearly 11 years now since those
scales were last reviewed clearly for
each of those officers there have been
some inflation related pay rises
in that time although you'll also
appreciate that's been a time of
austerity and in some years that was a
zero inflation so there was no actual
increase in those salaries i'll return
to that briefly when i get to
recommendation 3.7
recommendation 3.3 has then asked me to
look again at the job titles that's
something that i'm more than happy to do
and to have enshrined within here you
will know that we try and make sure that
we have job titles that are meaningful
not local government nonsense so they
actually describe what the person does
on the tin uh rather than something uh
that's possibly out of date or slightly
meaningless
and what's also important is that we
make sure that we've got job titles that
not just bespoke to baber but are
relevant in the wider local government
sector particularly important obviously
when we're coming to to recruit people
and also so that those officers can get
the foot in the door when they're trying
to negotiate or engage with other
partners unfortunately is still the case
where status in terms of job title does
help you get in the door at times
recommendation 3.4
is then to not limit this review
specifically to the senior leadership
team but to go beyond and look at the
rest of the workforce as well i know
that's something that lots of
councillors have raised i too think
that's absolutely critically important
it wasn't included within the original
report back in september because bluntly
it's something that's within my gift to
do already i don't need your permission
to make that happen but i know council
has wanted to see that enshrined in
there and specifically wanted to see a
time scale put on to that so you'll see
recommendation 3.4 now confirms that
that will happen and will happen by a
certain point in time so that that
affects the rest of the organization but
what's important in order to enable that
to happen is to create the financial
head room that isn't possible at the
moment because under the current scales
each of those officers bumps into the
next grade above if you do approve this
tonight then that will create some
headroom to be able to carry out that
wider review
recommendation 3.5
is then adding to that or in addition to
that it is again a recommendation that
came from councillors themselves and
again i wholeheartedly agree with which
is in relation to our pay progression
arrangements so at the moment if an
officer is going to progress up those
spinal points that i described those
five spinal points then in essence they
will do so if they've been here for an
extra year
and that they're not performing badly
i.e they're not on under some form of
special measures what that means by
default is that if you're just
performing all right
and you've been here another 12 months
you would progress up up that increment
scale until you reach the top and then
you would stop
and i don't think that's right and i
know council has said that they don't
think that's right either that if
there's going to be progression in terms
of increments it should be more directly
related to good performance not just
okay performance i don't think there's
any suggestion within this
recommendation and nor do counsellors
from what i've heard think that we
should have a formal uh
performance related pay scheme in the
kind of private sense private sector
sense of the word but a much closer
alignment to performance compared to
what we have today and so what's
proposed within that recommendation is
that that would happen for the senior
leadership team and then as you will
have read within the report if relevant
if appropriate that could be rolled out
more widely as well but that's not the
commitment that's within the report
tonight
3.6 is the formal bit of business which
is we are obliged or you are obliged on
an annual basis to approve a pay policy
statement and so you have within the
appendices that pay policy statement
tonight and we need to make sure that we
do that as i say on an annual basis that
was introduced by the government several
years ago and then lastly 3.7 builds on
that and what i said earlier which
essentially says notwithstanding the
requirement to look at the pay policy
statement on an annual basis that you
also would look to do a detailed review
of those salary scales at least every
four years and the reason being for that
that if you don't do that then there is
the potential to get yourself straight
back in the situation that you've found
yourselves in now whereby it hasn't been
reviewed for 10 years and it in effect
has built up a prolonged problem by
reviewing every four years would
hopefully avoid that build up or that
potential buildup
so those are the recommendations
councillors as i say they have come from
your own discussions and those at
mid-suffolk as well although i have to
say there was a lot of alignment in
views both across party and across the
two councils if there are any questions
more than happy to to try and answer
them either myself or through colleagues
for you and of course like the previous
report if you're so minded somebody else
will need to propose and second this
clearly it's not something i can do
thank you arthur
could i have a proposal please council
award and the second uh councillor
jamison
castle yeah uh thank you chad i don't
want to say an awful lot just that um
uh the chief executive has has made
reference to the uh 27 issues that were
raised by groups and individuals and the
fact that um each of those issues has
been addressed and
it has now worked that the
measures to address those issues have
worked their way into the report means
we do have a a much better report before
us now um than the one we had before
um
the
a couple of points that the chief
executive has has raised and i just
wanted to um
reiterate i'm very pleased to see a much
greater emphasis on performance in this
i think it's uh very important for for
this to
have the credibility that it needs
and also the the other point that the
chief executive mentioned was the the
need for headroom so that will allow us
to do a full review of all of the grades
below the senior leadership team so i
think this is a much better report and
one that we can support this evening
thank you chairman thank you john
councillor james do you wish to speak
um not at this stage chair but i will
come back at the end reserve the right
yeah thank you
so i'll just now move to questions and
debate
uh and we will now move to questions
um councillors may ask up to three
questions each however they must be
relevant to the subject under discussion
and must be a question
thank you who would like to start
councillor barrack melanie
sense of deja vu
thank you chair um
start off just uh with a couple of um
points i've noted from the policy um
there is a um
the reference to um
personally i would say i'd agree with
the proposal it can be helpful in um
tying
incremental progression with with good
performance
um
will that progression depend on
meeting your performance targets or
exceeding your performance targets
so that hasn't been finalized the
commitment here is to then look at that
i'd be interested in councillor's views
as to whether or not it should be
meeting or exceeding i think it would be
normal practice that if you are meeting
your targets that that would be uh
result in progression but of course a
lot of that will also depend upon how
stretching those targets are in the
first place and that will be absolutely
critical because if those targets are
set which there are set too easily to
reach then they become meaningless again
so we need to find the right balance
between stretching targets and
sensible targets we also also we also
will need to factor in of course
external elements to that uh none of us
predicted having a pandemic and what
that might do on your targets but of
course we look at performance related
issues on a regular basis not just once
a year so that could be built in as well
uh it's not something that's definitive
at this stage but i also think it will
be sensible if we're going down this
route to build in direct engagement with
councillors as well as you appreciate at
the moment all of the directors are
either directly managed by myself or by
the strategic director that wouldn't
change but in assessing their
performance i don't think it's right
that only one individual would be
assessing their performance i think that
would naturally make more sense to be
broadened in terms of that reflection
things like 360 reviews and i think it
would be sensible to include counsellors
opinions in that as well at the very
least
conscious of the vote that you had
earlier at the very least i would expect
that to include portfolio holders
of the relevant portfolio holders but it
may well go beyond that if that's
something that councillors are
interested in doing clearly the balance
that needs to be struck here is not
making it too bureaucratic uh certainly
what i don't want to get into for
example is a situation whereby a
decision is made and then there's a
whole system of appeals for example that
would start to undermine the whole
purpose of this but i think everyone
would sign up to the concept that it
should be as i said and thank you for
counseling barracks are supporting it
should be more directly linked to
performance but lots of that for
discussion interested in counseling this
views of course
i think
my second question um
this this report mentions um about four
or five times
the need to remind us that this is
public money
where is that addressed in the report
i'm not sure it is directly addressed
depending on what you mean by that so
absolutely right enshrined within our
pay policy statement is the need and i
haven't got the wording exactly in front
of me but i can find it if necessary is
to strike that balance between paying
what we need to pay based upon what's
fair and reasonable to pay for the work
that employees are doing based upon
their performance but also based upon
the market rate so to speak but a
recognition exactly as councillor
barrett has said a recognition that this
is taxpayers money and therefore that
needs to be factored into the equation
rather than simply being running running
around spending the money with no uh
acknowledgement to the fact that it's
taxpayers money the assessment that the
east of england lga have done for us has
focused on what are those benchmarks
what is the world look like out there
particularly in the eastern region what
is the in effect if i call it this the
right salary for the nature of the jobs
that we have
so they have focused on that element
it's for counsellors i would say and
that's why it's mentioned several times
within the report it's for councillors
to then do that assessment in
considering the recommendations as as to
whether or not that balance has been
struck
correctly but clearly that's not a right
or wrong black or white situation it's a
judgment that you will need to find us
do you think have we got that balance
right in terms of the investment of
public funds versus
having the the resources to be able to
deliver the priorities that you wanted
to see us deliver
um that's all right um
there's a there's a commitment to review
the remaining 570 staff
um in
a reasonable time scale i guess
um
if this is approved um
has the any thought being given to the
cost of that given that you know a
certain percentage of that will result
in a in an increase i would imagine
so absolutely right i would anticipate
that there's no point let's do the
review if everybody's salary comes back
as being exactly the same as it started
of course things can go up and things
can go down in that regard the review
and suzanne may want to comment on it or
just nod when i say this it isn't
something that we would be able to carry
out in-house as you'd expect we don't
have the resource sitting there ready to
do a complete review of 570 odd staff
that would be something that i would
suggest we bring in in order to hit
those time scales so we bring in some
additional capacity to help us with that
but i would anticipate having been
through similar experiences in other
authorities in the past that actually
what you will be presented with and it
will be you that will be presented with
it with this is not a definitive there
you go here's the answer it will be
options because there won't be one one
simple solution it will be a series of
options for you the time scales work
very well completely by chance rather
than by design because i would hope to
get those options to you ahead of
setting the budget next year
so you would have those options in front
of you before you get to the february uh
full council meeting and therefore you
could consider the cost implications of
any changes alongside setting the budget
assuming of course that you wish you
wished to implement it from the first of
april the following year so first of
april 2023 if you do that on those time
scales then you would have set aside the
money and you will have known what you
were doing and you've done that through
the budget in a very
straightforward and logical order
ordering so to speak but you're
absolutely right council about i would
anticipate there were there are
financial consequences clearly they're
not yet known because we haven't started
that work that would follow from this uh
and uh i think i'll probably fully
answer the question
councilman clara
thank you chair
um
i actually believe in
competitive pay in a competitive world
so i will be supporting
these recommendations however
um i think increase in pay brings
increase in responsibility and i'm
pleased to see the emphasis on
performance i think we we all have to be
measured as to how we perform and i
think that applies to the offices as
well but i'm going to ask you a question
that i was asked by the peer review
group which i couldn't answer and that
was are there corporate competencies
in this
establishment and in this council
thank you
yes we already have a suite of core
corporate competencies that we assess uh
people buy on an annual basis that's
both their performance but as we said
this would strengthen it in terms of
directly aligning to to pay but it also
stretches into values and behaviors as
well so not just
have they delivered the outcome that was
set for them but how did they go about
delivering that outcome was it done in
the right way not just achieved
for the sake of it as it were so yes
absolutely we do they're not static then
again they're not things that just stay
set in stone because the world keeps
changing and again i suspect they are
things in fact i think they're on the uh
in the people plan they're one of the
things that we want to look at as well
it's scheduled in uh not as past
directly as part of this work but just
on the basis we need to make sure that
those are always up to date and
appropriate for the modern local
government world as opposed to what
would have been possibly appropriate in
the past so the arts short answer yes
thank you thank you
councillor michael fraser
thank you mr chairman um
you've i think you've alluded to where
where am i where the answer would be for
my question but uh
you the pay scales as i understand it
have been reviewed by the easter bank
east of england local government
association and you're looking at
comparable rates of salary for the jobs
they do but how does this compare with
other areas of the public sector
[Music]
i'm focused on one area from my
background the armed forces and what's
been
proposed here
you're looking at an assistant director
being on a similar pay scale to an
officer grade 4 lieutenant colonel
in charge of
550 plus personnel
uh strategic director is in one star
general sort of level of pay so how does
local government these local government
suggested rates compared to
other areas of the public sector please
i think i have to bow to your expertise
in relation to the comparisons to the
military
i suppose the first thing to note is
and sometimes confused particularly for
the public local government isn't the
civil service so local government
officers are not civil servants so there
isn't a direct comparison that you can
do across for example even to the
department for communities and local
government as was because there isn't
that direct comparison across we do know
and it's within the report that if you
do the comparison say with the health
sector
we know because we've tried to recruit
less than 12 months ago that we are
behind the salaries in relation to the
health sector and this would bring it up
if this is approved would bring it up to
about comparable but it is very
difficult to do compare and contrast
across the wider public sector because
clearly the roles are very very
different so the east of england lga
haven't tried to do that i wouldn't
suggest for one minute that that's what
you've got before you tonight what
you've got is very directly a comparison
against our sector as the local
government sector in terms of the
eastern region and beyond
and yes you're right you will find
differences if you were to look as i say
uh if you look to a police if you look
to armed forces or if you look to the
health sector as being the obvious other
bits of the public sector of course
there are other elements as well so this
report doesn't attempt to do that
nor and i might try and bring in steve
here they may want to comment in terms
of what normal practice is not such for
normal practice for baby but normal
practice within the sector as a whole so
chairman bring in mr davis
yes um
i would concur with uh um
arthur that
other um organizations um or local
government i've reviewed um uh paying a
number of um london authorities in the
past and predominantly we look at our
local market which is uh
local government for comparison and
identifying what the appropriate
levels of pay might be because that's
predominantly the sector that you're uh
fishing in if you like in terms of poor
obviously you're looking to track
sometimes people outside that sector but
in terms of actual pay
um the reference to
determining pay arrangements you look
within your own sector and that's um
what the east of england lga have done
and that's included in the report i
would just add that i did some of my own
comparison from um wider benchmarking on
other districts in the southeast and
west midlands because i'm privy to that
information because i manage a metric
service that does um information for
those regions as well and um
and the east of
england lga
information concurs with
that wider pool of
metrics as well
thank you mr davidson
castle fraser
yeah just if i come back there so just
to confirm so what the east of england
lga is proposing is pretty much on par
nationally
certainly within um
this
part of the country
and compared to south east and west
midlands i can concur that that's um
comparative yes
thank you mr davis
any other questions
then i shall proceed to go to the debate
and
once again um
uh
councils will have uh the uh
three minutes
uh but only speak once on that and there
will be timed
so who would like to start a debate
please
counselor parish melanie murray i can't
resist
um
i think
i have
some
sympathy with
the the predicament of having to
ensure that we are competitive we've got
to attract the right people to it but i
i think the increase is proposed a bit
excessive
and this is a really a problem for a
number of reasons
um uh because we could be embarking on a
much larger increase as we've just been
discussing in questions
um if we embrace this
review across
a significant number of people there's
we're just talking about nine people in
this review we've got 570 other staff
you know what what are we what are we
embarking on here
um
can we
can we afford it
it is a bit of a concern really can we
actually afford this
um
it's a for another reason as well that i
i think the um
the um
the the excess it troubles me
um because if we agree this it it pushes
the
the prospect of our chief executive
salary is going to need to be elevated
because the his
his strategic director
will be they'll be overlap with his
salary and the his uh his number two
um so really that's not a situation that
you would normally have
um and excuse me for taking a little
swipe out but it's interesting that in
the report our offices offices are
described as modern
um
and beneficial to attracting um staff
perhaps they don't need a quarter of a
million spending on them then
um so if we agree this we could be
responsible for creating an exodus
from other councils um to come and come
and work for baber they'll be they'll be
keen to to do that
um putting pressure on our fellow you
know our neighboring councils
um to perform exactly the same review
that we're doing
and are we gonna then end up in a sort
of a
upward pressure on neighbouring councils
for the next couple of years
who is the winner in this
um
i i believe this proposal is is is too
excessive so i won't be supporting it
i'm afraid
i'm a little confused chairman to hear
that this looks as though it's some you
know a ridiculous amount of money
according to the paper 9.1 states that
our combined salary budget
is 21.2 million
that's the combined budget for everybody
and the increasing cost
over the period including on costs
um
annual financial impact will vary from
5848 to 18
288 because we can only consider what's
in this paper
not the future pay review that maybe
coming forward once arthas got that done
by the end of i think it's the end of
the financial year 2023
so
if we just take what in front of us in
the paper then we don't see a great
increase in fact the previous paper
didn't have that great an increase the
fact of the matter is
one interim
appointment costs us
more than another chief executive would
we are spending we spend we don't want
interims
when we get an interim we spend a
fortune on them this is designed to help
us avoid having to get into rooms
because we haven't got enough candidates
coming forward at the money we can pay
them so i'll be supporting the paper
thank you
counselor
simon barrett
i think there needs to be a clarity
about interim
an interim is there to replace an
officer that is not imposed
so to infer that an interim is excessive
over and above is actually slightly uh
incorrect and interim obviously is a
cost
that would be replaced so yes there is
additional cost but it's not the
enormous cost that's been portrayed by
councillor mccraw
so i think that needs to be taken into
account
slightly alarmist i think because
obviously when you have interims
they are there to replace we have one
interim at the moment which is there
because we couldn't recruit and the
reason we couldn't recruit is if you
look at the job it's made up of four
employers and who wants to work for four
employees is bad enough working for one
so i think the job description was
probably wrong it didn't attract the
right number of people hence we've got
a an interim in that post but is that
interim actually much more expensive
probably not in the long term because
there are on costs the interims do not
have council macro in terms of the
pension contribution which equates to 33
percent
so we're not paying that
so i think you need to take that into
account without you without your
slightly alarmist views on interims and
slightly inaccurate ones
thank you
councillor michael fraser
thank you mr chairman um
i i would just like to encourage a bit
more debate on this because i'm
undecided
i'm open-minded rather i haven't decided
which way i was going to vote on this
and i'd like to really understand
the wider views of the council on this
is it affordable
or not so i'd really encourage debate
thank you
councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman um
two two things that really i would like
to to get clarified to a certain extent
in my own mind as well
three recommendation 3.4 that's subject
to approval of recommendations 3.1 and
3.2
i can understand that if we
elevate the lower members of staff
they're going to bump into the
upper members of staff's salary unless
we push the other members of staff up
but the review of the
pay structure across the whole workforce
shouldn't be dependent upon what happens
to the upper members of staff it should
happen anyway
whether it's implemented or not should
then be the math at all discussion
um but we shouldn't be almost
blackmailed into approving the other
members of staff so that we can improve
the conditions for law members
especially when we have just waited 10
months to give them their agreed pay
increase
the other point i would would like to
cover is the fact that
we've heard about
local governments
a different organization even to the
civil service
to the health service
to the armed forces
and therefore we've got to fish in the
local government pool
well not necessarily if we fished in the
armed forces pool
from what uh
our colleague on the other side of the
chamber's been saying we'd be
quids in
we'd get a one star general for the same
sort of money as we're getting
an ordinary sort of person if you like
so we should be expanding our
recruitment so that we don't end up
with this same few people chasing high
salaries around the local government
sector if there's more competition there
we'll get good performance from from
officers and good value for money that's
what we should be looking for because as
it says in the report
we've got to remember this is the
public's money
council davis
i find myself in the unusual position of
agreeing with both council hinton and
councillor barrett melody barrett of
course
the points that have been made about the
the ongoing um
increases especially within the local
government area you know it's a bit of
an analogy in terms of football
transfers and football footballers wages
you know that just increases increases
increases because it's a relatively
small pool of players available the
difference is of course they have
sponsorship they have tv deals and they
have
billions coming in from richover seeds
owners
so i think we need to to be careful
about doing that i think
they're not here but i think our
officers do a fantastic job and i would
love to see them get more money but i
think we have to be realistic and
exactly as as councillor hinton has said
you know maybe we need to look outside
that pool a little bit and the other
thing is in-house training we've just
appointed melania sorry melissa we've
just
promoted melissa and that's exactly what
we should be doing you know promoting
from within
gaining those experience whether it's
from the nhs the armed forces or other
other sectors as well
my biggest concern though is the where
the increases go it leaves the the
junior officers and and those middle
officers behind that gap gets wider and
wider you know and appreciate we have to
deal with unions in terms of the
officers and and the government saying
it's just one percent or two percent but
especially in the current climate i
think i'd really struggle as much as i'd
love to give our senior officers more
money i'd really struggle to actually do
that
any other questions
thank you um
i don't have a problem with paying
people what they're worth
and from what's been said tonight is
gauging that performance and their worth
to us as an organization
but that's if we can afford it
and from what i've seen over the seven
years i've been a councillor is the
increase the continual increase of the
salaries of the wages the budget
and the percentage of what we actually
have spent on that wages budget each
year it seems to go up and up and up
there has to come a point when we draw a
line and say can we actually afford what
we're proposing
so
i would actually support this but i
would urge us as an authority as a
council
to seriously consider having a cap
and given the chief executive a budget
to spend on wages and keep them within
that budget and running the authority
with that cap in place
because i can see the continual
increases that we have
will gradually be higher and higher and
higher year on year on year
and it's going to cause us a problem in
the long run as i say i think similar to
council davis i think our officers do a
fantastic job i think they should be
rewarded for that and that reward should
be what the
national pay scheme
um offers and for what we've heard from
mr davis um certainly what we're
proposing is within that locally and
regionally
i think we do have a bigger issue here
long term about what we can actually
afford and i think we seriously need to
consider that as an authority but i will
be supporting this people
thank you
if it's legally possible to have a cap
i know that isn't football
after someone mentioned about rich
footballers so even in this instance i
don't know
if there's anything you could do to have
a cat i don't think you could do that
thank you counselor
anyhow any other person wishing to take
into debate
oh councillor jameson
do you wish to
sir yeah uh thank you yeah i'm good i'm
not saying it's um dreadful that we've
got ourselves in this difficult
situation situation we've left 11 years
to um
to review our senior management team
and it's um it's good to see that we're
not going to be doing that in the future
um
i understand what a lot of um counselors
have said here about being
[Music]
expensive can we afford it
and when we first came here
a few months ago i it looked to me a
huge pay rise for uh for our own
directors
and um
i'm pleased for the explanation it
doesn't seem to be now that anyone's
going to get more than about three
percent pay rise
um
now i know that's still going to be
difficult for residents to
to accept
but i do think we need to do it on this
occasion and we'll be supporting it and
i'm
i'm happy to see
that and i hope we do
um look at uh the rest of the
members of staff there's a four going to
be a full pay review going forward over
the next year and i don't think that
needs to be forgotten
thanks
for jameson
councilwood do you wish to come back is
there anything you wish to add
uh yeah thank thanks serge sir jeremy
just just a few things actually um
we're not actually uh chasing upwards
we're just trying to maintain parity
with some of our uh neighbouring
councils because we are falling behind
um what we've got proposed is affordable
is in the budget
um
the
yes it might initially
give us a wider gap between
the senior levels and other stuff but we
are going to be filling that gap it
gives us a headroom to fill that gap
in the review of all pay
but i think one of the questions we've
got to ask is if not now then when do we
do it we've already said that we're
falling behind
and so we need to really think about it
uh
the issue about recruiting from within
um
that that's really not really relevant
it's not mitigation for not paying our
officers
the right level for for the job and as
we've several of us have said they do
work very very hard
um and and and do do justify it
uh the the interim uh issue is is a
significant one interims do cost uh they
can cost anything from uh six seven
hundred up to a thousand twelve hundred
maybe more a day
um and the fact that we had to uh
uh recruit an interim in the the
community's aed um
is testament to the fact that we are
struggling to recruit so uh we do need
to bear in mind that that interim cost
uh i think that's probably oh the only
other things a couple of things i wanted
to say uh i know there's some reference
to the chief exec salary and that is
outside of the scope of what we're
proposing this evening but there isn't
an overlap between his salary and that
of the strategic director so i don't
think we need to worry too much about
that
and finally i know there's been some
reference to footballer salaries
and wages but i quite honestly that's
that's kind of offensive but we know
that footballers are ridiculously
overpaid um
and i don't think there's any comparison
really with our officers our senior
leadership team that works very very
hard
and
for salaries which
as we have seen whereas we have evidence
are falling behind um the uh their
comparable uh salaries at other councils
locally and and further afield
nationally so i think that uh it's the
right time to do this it's affordable
and we will see the benefits of of that
um so i'm
fully um in support of this and i think
it's it's it's time that we do this
thank you chairman thank you councillor
ward
chief executive do you wish you oh sorry
well you've spoken once i'm afraid well
it's to clarify
some information clarification
throughout time okay yeah just looking
at the
the proposal is for the strategic
director's pay to be increased to 120
but the bottom of the chief executives
pay might not be the current salary that
is received the bottom point is 118 000
isn't that correct
no it's been uplifted following the last
inflation rise so the the bottom of that
salary is actually slightly higher than
120.
right thank you
all right
thank you
do you wish to add anything
i should go to the vote now
so i ask
our corporate manager governance and
civic office to conduct the electronic
vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for councillors to cast their
vote
okay thank you chair the votes are now
in and the voting is sixteen four
five against and four abstentions so
that report is carried
it's entirely up to you members do you
wish
catherine can you
sorry
so now move to
uh item 14
uh bc 2142
decisions taken by the chief executive
under delegate powers in accordance with
part two of the constitution
i would like to invite monitoring
officer to introduce paper bc 2142 which
is for noting
thank you chairman the council is asked
to note the schedule of decisions taken
by the chief executive under delegated
authority
one of the decisions
grants an extended leave of absence for
council at grandin due to ill health
there are two decisions which relate to
urgent actions that were needed to
enable the council to respond to the
increase in the omicron variant of the
covert virus earlier this year
and the final five relate to the making
of neighbourhood plans in a number of
areas following successful referendum
results thank you
thank you emily
um
i'd now like to go to item 15 council
report appointments
do we have any changes
council ward
okay
so we get to item 16
uh motions on notice
and i refer to the motions on notice in
the table papers
16a to consider the motion on notice
received from council ward
council award would you like to move
your motion
could i have a sector please
yeah i would uh like to uh to move the
motion as as it's um presented in the
the agenda supplement papers um we all
know what's going on in in ukraine um
it's it's appalling and um there has
been this this is a standard motion that
a number of councils are
are proposing and voting on
just to to
reiterate that baby district council is
immensely troubled by the horrific
devastation in ukraine and the
escalating humanitarian crisis facing
the country
and in the light of this and as a way of
expressing support for members of our
communities who are from who have ties
with ukraine this council condemns the
unprovoked russian invasion of ukraine
and stands in solidarity with the people
of ukraine
and their families and friends including
those local to suffer
it also stands ready to provide support
to those affected by this war and will
open our arms to people displaced and
affected and finally we will work with
and support the efforts of our local
communities to provide help and comfort
to those in need thank you chairman
could i have a second to please
councillor zach norman
would you like to speak
reserve your room
well of course um we all we all know
what's going on and as um as council
aboard has already said uh i think we
would all agree to um to stand in
solidarity with ukraine here as it's all
been um originally in the papers so yeah
i'm very happy to second this thank you
we've now moved to debate
councillor hinton what do you wish to
say
when it's part question part for the
debate really i agree entirely with the
wording on the on the motion but what i
would just like to have clarified
is that if
occupant single occupant homes in this
district offer accommodation to
ukrainian refugees that they won't lose
their discount on their council taxes
has happened in certain parts of the
country the council itself will get ten
and a half thousand pounds per refugee
to help with education health etc
but
the occupant of the house who's who is
giving
sanctuary to ukrainian refugees is is in
danger in quite a lot of places of
losing their discount off their council
tax which is a 25 discount for single
occupancy
thank you
yeah
thank you so council hinton raises an
absolutely valid point which is that
concern that that if our local residents
take in somebody from uh from abroad
from ukraine that there is that risk
i have taken from the sentiment that
this council has expressed on numerous
occasions in relation to
what's going on in ukraine that you
wouldn't wish us to apply that ieu would
ask us not to remove the single person
discount i'm taking that as read and
therefore we will apply that policy
accordingly if that needs a formal
decision then i will liaise with the
monetary officer and we'll make that
formal decision in due course if it's
something that officers can just do then
then we will go away and do that unless
i hear strong views to the country but i
suspect i won't
thank you
thank you arthur
i'd now
like to to continue with the debate
council davis
um yeah it's debating the question at
the same time so i totally support the
motion that you've done and also support
what you said in your opening address
about supporting the homes for ukraine
refugees but what i would ask you to do
what i'd ask the council to do
because i have a number of people in
shortly and indeed on the whole of the
stunning shotly peninsula who have
already applied to take refugees i've
already got businesses that want to a
accommodate refugees and give them work
and they've applied online and they've
heard absolutely nothing so please will
you tell your masters in whitehall to
get their finger out and get this sorted
so these people can't get here
thank you councillor douglas councillor
jan osborne
i don't wish to
any any other on this debate
sorry oh
council ward do you wish to add anything
um just uh in in response to council
davis um that message is is being heard
loud and clear um
all
local authorities are somewhat
frustrated in the fact that we don't yet
have detailed instructions on how we can
help with with that process
we are immensely frustrated and we will
as soon as we get some more clarity from
government take our full part in in
helping to match
um that those are offering accommodation
with those that need it and also of
course as you quite rightly point out in
terms of finding jobs for them because
we all know there are lots of job
vacancies here and we would like we
would love as many ukrainians as
possible to come here and fill those job
vacancies and as a council we would do
everything we can to to support that as
long as the government does give us the
uh the assistance and the authority to
do that
[Music]
just to request on the basis of that
when that does happen would it be
possible for it to be communicated to
all members so that we're aware and also
able to advise people on
perhaps how the government scheme i know
i've had phone calls and other people
have about various possibilities and
again lack of information coming forward
so if we do get information could it be
disseminated through the council thank
you
chief executive would like to yeah
absolutely there has been some guidance
published by government it doesn't go as
far as i suspect all of us want it to do
we'll make sure that that's circulated
in any event and then as that comes
through circulate any further
information and guidance that's without
saying
thank you
i'll now like to go to the vote so i'll
now ask the corporate manager governance
and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for councillors to cast their
vote
are you um
okay it won't go thank you
and cancer dawson are you that's four
okay lovely thank you
chair that voting is 27 for that's
unanimous
thank you that is carried
no it's sorry
sorry it's 25 for sorry
i'd now like to go to item 16b to
consider the motion of notice received
from councillor jameson
councillor jameson would you like to
move your motion
thank you um if i put this motion
through originally with ukraine in mind
obviously and at the time i wasn't aware
of council awards motion
but uh i i think it's still
um worthwhile motion
ukraine the ukrainian crisis is just the
latest
of many humanitarian crisis across the
world we have afghanistan
we've still got yemen syria
um
numerous countries in africa and we
don't know where the next crisis is
coming from
so the city of sanctuary or or cat
council of sanctuary there's various
names
a quarter of local authorities are now
signed up to be a council of sanctuary
and it's an umbrella organization whose
mission is to provide coordination
and support
uh councils for
local community groups networks
to make sure that
when we are putting together policies
when we are thinking about for example
was given to me was leisure we think
about
people seeking sanctuary in this country
people whose first language may not be
english
and we need to put that
they work with us we sign up
and they'll sit down with us and go
through that and work with us set up um
[Music]
panels
just have a panel to sit down with us
and
work through
our policies and how they work for
people who seek entry in this country
and within our districts
so that's why i thought it's still
worthwhile putting this forward i mean
it can help
it can work alongside the previous
motion but going forward i mean
you sign up for three years
and then you
you reapply after the three years
and it sort of embeds
people who seek sanctuary within all our
policies and as i say a quarter of local
authorities have signed up ipswich
already a city of sanctuary
and i think it would be worthwhile if we
signed up and sat down
with the um
the group to um
it'd be a big benefit for our council
sorry
so jameson could i have a second of
these
council
[Music]
now move to debate
councils will only be allowed to speak
once for three minutes
and this will be timed
we would like to start the debate
council award
yeah i'd just say a few things i noticed
that the um the motion itself refers to
the city of sanctuary and i know council
jameson um mentioned council sanctuary
and i've had a look at the website that
he's provided a link to and uh he does
use the phrase council of sanctuary i
think that is far more appropriate it's
more inclusive city of sanctuary does
does tend to uh uh suggest that um we're
not worthy of being communities of
sanctuary but um but clearly we are
um
we're living in an increasingly
dangerous world that's that's no
quite obvious to all of us um
there's so many problems um and we are
fortunate to live in one of the best
places
where best parts of one of the best
countries in the world one of the most
welcoming countries one of the the
freest countries and the one of the most
tolerant countries
um so
[Music]
i have no problems with with this motion
either so
thank you chairman hey
castleborn any other wish to go into the
debate
councillor owen would you like to
well yeah um
there's no debate i i think this is a
very well worth cause and i i believe
that there's a lot of problems in the
world and
we should help them
so
councillor jameson is there anything you
wish to add
no thanks uh yeah
then i shall proceed to go to the vote
and i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and service office to conduct
the electronic vote thank you chair that
is now showing in blue for councillors
to cast their vote
chair we have the results of the vote
it's 22 4 and three abstentions
so that is carried thank you
that is carried
councillors
um
i'd just like to
add a few comments uh
regarding the meeting of our next
our next council meeting which will be
wednesday please take note it's
wednesday the 25th of may
so is everybody happy with that
yeah so
it's the 27th
25th of may yeah
you